hanging off the side of the plane yes
you could do that CG but he doesn't want
to
yes I didn't tell my family or friends
or anyone I was doing it beforehand when
you're on the side of a plane there's so
many factors that could go wrong that
was the first time I'd ever seen him
nervous yeah because we're worried about
bird strikes I had contact lenses it was
very cold and then Tom shouts if I look
like I'm panicking I'm acting
don't cut we're we're up there about
250. on the second take I got hit by a
pebble we were going so fast luckily it
hit my rib I I thought it broke my rib I
was
gosh if that was up just a little bit it
would have gone through my skull it took
about two weeks actually for my
temperature to kind of my body to kind
of settle back in it's like it's not
like you don't feel that that fear it's
just it doesn't stop me from doing it I
kind of enjoy that feeling look I do it
because it's it's entertaining to you
all you honestly don't have to have film
in the camera but the truth of the
matter is he would just hang off the
side
let's go